if your mother was near death
well the first thing you do is call an
online publication Wendy Williams
manager addressing her son Kevin Hunter
Jr's tabloid claims I'm not trying to
have a debate with Kevin I'm not here to
be combative about you know whatever
allegations he has
you know he's entitled to his opinion
I'm just trying to say that us as adults
let's be responsible and let's actually
utilize some common sense you know
someone was near death someone like your
mother
why would you go to an online
publication to discuss it with them
Kevin made headlines Tuesday when he
made explosive statements about his
mother's team in an interview with the
U.S son the 22 year old accused them of
taking advantage of her health while she
allegedly struggled with alcoholism and
encouraged her to work despite her
health issues no people forget that she
deals with lymphedema people forget that
she deals with Graves disease we should
at least exhibit some type of care and
or at least acknowledgment you know for
someone who's going through a lot
but according to Wendy's manager will
Selby her finances are well protected
Wendy is under a guardianship
everything that she does gets approved
by the guardianship a court-appointed
guardianship so no one even if they
wanted to could take advantage of her
everything has to get approved by that
court so any type of business dealings
that we do but yet the guardianship to
sign off on
so how can anyone take advantage of her
in a statement to E.T Wendy's publicist
Sean zanotti also weighed in on the sun
interview saying this publication has
released false narratives which is a
disturbance to the public and is
unprofessional and unethical and as far
as Wendy's alleged alcoholism will says
the situation is under control Wendy is
taking the steps to um be in a better
space she's progressing very well she
looks healthy she sounds healthy and I
think she's doing amazing you know as of
today
so you know I'm not a doctor but that's
my synopsis on how Wendy's doing right
now Wendy is at a facility doing her
best to be her best she's taking it day
by day I felt like I could do this
Kevin's accusations have some wondering
if Wendy's aware of it all if she talks
to me and she asks me about it then yeah
we'll have a conversation but that's not
that's not a concern you know she's only
thinking about things that she wants to
do in her life she's only thinking about
Wendy 2.0 and her new chapter of her
life and you know the things that she
wants to accomplish and that's our Focus
I have options out the Wazoo that I did
not have back then
and and I have Clarity like I've never
had before as far as Wendy's Health goes
Wendy's manager says things are looking
up she's in good spirits she's happy she
she is so ambitious she loves to work
she profusely tells me ideas and
thoughts and and I think she wants to do
next yeah and for all those wondering if
she should be working in her condition
will believes she's ready for it all all
she wants to do is conquer the world she
wants to help people she wants to
um be out there and utilize her voice
you know we have to remember Wendy's
like
a verbal Instagram she is the you know
the initial
um art of basically exposing perception
you know she is an icon she's done so
much and we're just ready to tear it
down he also addresses reality TV show
rumors I know Wendy wants to do a
podcast she is excited about doing a
podcast she feels like it's the best of
both worlds where they get to hear her
voice and then they get her you know
visually you know doing her thing so
that to my knowledge is still something
that she's embarking on but reality show
come on like seriously she's not
shooting a reality show that's been fall
since day one and whatever day we're on
right now is still false
[Music]